foreign
[Music]
yeah bro let's hit some of these Angelic
yields last week we watched a bunch of
these tick tocks of people stealing [ __ ]
from their High School it became a huge
issue yeah I was talking about this to
somebody at the bar they were like yeah
my my girlfriends whatever works for the
high school like a high school around
here and they were like same thing there
someone ripped off the urinal flooded
the whole place so funny it was just
like a horrible Trend everywhere the
kids were just wreaking havoc on their
schools and so someone took it upon
themselves to start this trend Angelic
yield Angelic yield because the other
one was called devious lick
oh please yeah there will be
consequences now this is the start of
this
[Music]
calming jazz music and he just what the
[ __ ]
um I'm hoping this can help someone bro
Gabby potato citing playing over that
music is so seriously that's dark as
[ __ ] don't laugh that's not funny
that's not funny
Australia
so [ __ ] up oh my God two angelic
yields at once
it fills up
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's pretty funny damn says people
just like doing good things like being
generous leaving [ __ ] places like
someone took a 10 Bill and just laid it
under the seat of the toilet nice for
the next dude to come in and find
to have the Holy
holiest yield for one of my students the
holiest yield oh [ __ ] okay let this go
my students
[Music]
decided oh what so he confiscated a note
from Trevor to Chloe that said do you
want to be my girlfriend and the teacher
confiscated it and then he moved them
next door to each other
oh what a sweet guy yeah she's like
[ __ ] ew was that she just leave the
TV
is that a [ __ ] TV
no way
oh my gosh it's kind of a hilarious and
it's so funny this is so good this is
when Tick Tock is actually good yeah
he's had a plug right there
[Music]
just put a TV above the [ __ ] sinks
[Music]
damn dude that's [ __ ] amazing that's
so funny yeah I feel awful for laughing
at The Gabby potato thing that's just so
[ __ ] dude I'm so sorry I feel awful
for laughing at that I wasn't laughing
at the situation just the timing of
that's the timing yeah no one thinks
that you're laughing at the sick so and
so cash that's but I woke up in the
morning on Sunday and someone had bought
someone at my house had ordered
Chick-fil-A so it was like a bunch of
empty Chick-fil-A bags around and then
I picked up one of them and it was still
closed and I was like what the [ __ ] is
this yeah some food that someone left
and I opened it up it was three of the
giant Chick-fil-A sauces like the
bottles of it three all on unopened why
I was like because somebody just
just hit the most Angelic yield in my
place and just
yeah just gifted me three Mega sauces
damn I felt blessed as hell truly
trying to think what Angelic yield I
would hit I'd bring a Squatty Potty just
like the thing for your to hike your
feet up when you're dump that's good
just put those in each stall yeah or
maybe bring like some noise canceling
thing the funniest thing was I came
across one of those tick tocks so it's
like don't get caught pooping at school
and like people just like harassing them
just like are you pooping in there
yeah yeah
what's wrong
yeah I was like
I was dying laughing and then
Alina looked at that and she's like no
one did that in high school I was like
yeah they did she's like where I'm like
a boy's bathroom [ __ ] yeah oh yeah dude
and like I had like booming was the
scariest thing ever so I'm scared I
remember this kid yo he would um he was
super tall as well he would shake the
stall doors you know everyone did that
like oh yeah I have it I have it hold on
but his thing was to look over to see if
he knew who was [ __ ] no that's
I want to say he popped over one time
he's I was taking a [ __ ] I'm just
shaking my head I'm like here he comes I
would swear to God he looked over he's
like I'm like bro get out get out
someone pooping someone pooping
smell good bro
you said bro
flush that all right
hey bro
hey bro you pumpkin
you know the kids like it smells good
smells good what you cooking in there
bro what you cooking in there
bro you okay
bro
you pooping you know the kid's just like
unlock the door right quick
bro not the door unlock the door so holy
smoke
oh my gosh
you know
the cashing on this is horrible man I
like what I like oh he smells so damn
smells so damn good
oh
are you pooping dudes with black Air
Forces like tucked together knowing the
meme around black Air Forces
he's just thinking about murder in there
the whole time like I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill this dude
ah caught me [ __ ] in black Air Force
instead of bullying me I know that boy's
heart was racing yeah
oh he smells so damn good shaking the
stall door is violent man
I have PTSD hearing that noise just that
[ __ ] was so funny too like
you know you just go take a piss with
your like like two of you might go to
the bathroom like you might go use the
urinals separately like washing your
hands and then someone would be like hey
hold on and they just walk down to the
[ __ ] stall and just bang on whoever
just taking this [ __ ]
like before I get out of here let me hit
this real quick
[Laughter]
stress the [ __ ] out of this kid right
now
[Music]
I have something to clean that up
you smell something stinky
oh that is way too far dude what the
[ __ ] no one was harmed or bullied in
this video
thank you
oh my god dude that's so wrong man
1.0 GPA activities